the shooting down of the US drone was
announced on Iranian state television
they did not immediately broadcast any
pictures of the attack but showed
instead a file image of the type of
drone they said had been hit an unmanned
surveillance aircraft used for gathering
imagery of large areas of land in all
weathers iran's elite Revolutionary
Guard commander said it had destroyed
the drone because it wanted to send a
strong message to the u.s. those who
defend the borders of the Islamic nation
of Iran will react in a total and
decisive way to any intrusions by
foreign elements on our land our borders
are our redline an enemy that violates
our borders will not return and will be
destroyed the commander went on to say
that Iran was ready for war but added
that they did not seek conflict with any
nation however the incident comes at a
time of increasing tension between
Tehran and Washington at its heart the
international nuclear deal which the
u.s. withdrew from last year this week
Iran said it was also no longer willing
to abide by the terms of the agreement
and could soon restart its nuclear
activity also raising concerns are
attacks on two oil tankers in the Gulf
of Oman on Wednesday the US military
presented more evidence
it said linked Tehran to the incidents
Iran for its part denies involvement the
United States has also said it has no
interest in fueling the dispute with
around but the fear is a military
confrontation could happen not by design
but by accident
and we're joined now by simon Maeva and
lecturer at in international relations
at lancaster university and you know
simon as we've seen their tensions
between these two countries they've been
increasing for some time
this development yeah is it surprising
to you know particularly I think if we
look back over over the past few months
and particularly the past few weeks
we've seen that both Iran in the United
States and also Saudi Arabia are all
getting increasingly concerned about
what's happening in the Gulf they're
becoming more and more suspicious of
each other and as a consequence it's
hardly surprising that the United States
would be launching these types of drones
trying to get a better picture of what
Iran is doing thinking that if it is
provoking around if it is putting this
pressure on Iran economically militarily
politically then Iran might lash out and
I guess that would be the the obvious
thing to do to look at what Iran is
doing to try and get a sense of of
whether it is at that point of launching
any type of attack but then of course
Iran would be on the lookout for they
said on the lookout for any penetration
of his airspace and and if there is any
doubt about US drones or indeed any
drones flying into Iran's airspace right
now given that it's on the defensive
given that it's also politically charged
then it would certainly do something
like this we have some very strong
rhetoric I mean the country saying that
it is ready for war given that Simon
where do you see this going I mean
further escalation possible here well I
think your your little package just
before you you came to me did a very
good job of summing all of that up in
the sense that it's not necessarily that
states will want war the danger here is
that war will happen accidentally it's
not in the US interests for them to go
to war with Iran President Trump has
repeatedly said he does not want to
commit US forces more into the Middle
East Saudi Arabia doesn't necessarily
want war but its Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Salman has said we are ready for war
if it comes to it Iran doesn't want war
the Iranian economy has been damaged
massively by the economic sanctions
placed on the state after the u.s.
withdrew
from the nuclear deal so it's not really
in anyone's interests the pragmatic
response is not to have a conflict here
because it will be devastating but not
just the states in question but also for
the region and for international actors
as well but the danger is in this
climate of increased risk increased
instability increased fear that someone
does something and is perceived in a
different way or someone does something
accidentally and it triggers something
and that's exactly what your package
said and I mean you're seeing no signs
here of de-escalation in fact the United
States already announcing that it's
sending 1000 more troops to the regions
so Simon can you can you see either side
here really backing down are they stuck
in this game of chicken I think that's
probably a good way of looking at it
that neither side can really afford to
lose face here we know that Trump is
embarking on a presidential reelection
campaign he's not one for four new ones
really in his rhetoric he's he's
bombastic he's not going to back down
but neither can the Iranians their faith
their very survival is on the line they
will not back down in the face of of the
United States so it's not going to be a
case of someone backing down from the
other what it will take is a different
stay the different organizations
stepping up and saying right we need to
do something we need to mediate we need
to have some diplomatic back channels
and we know that there are back channels
open between the Saudis and the Iranians
and various other actors but we need to
know that they're open right now that
both sides and the United States are
willing to talk to one another because
if not then we will see this game of
chicken getting more and more dangerous
so I'm a bond from Lancaster University
thank you thank you